Wo ist mein Handy?
Entschuldigung. Ich habe dich nicht verstanden.
Ich habe dich gefragt, wo mein Handy ist.
Das weiss ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Es liegt neben dem Fernseher.
Es liegt auf dem Tisch.
Ist es in deiner Jackentasche?
Nein, es ist nicht in meiner Jackentasche?
Wo bist du?
Was?
Sag mir, wo du bist?
Ich bin in der Schule.
Ich bin im Einkaufszentrum.
Ich bin in einem Restaurant.
Ich bin in der Bank.
Ich bin im Bus.
Ich bin bei der Friseurin.
Ich bin beim Arzt.
Ich bin bei Tom.
Ich bin zu Hause.
Ich bin in Berlin.
Wohin gehst du?
Ich gehe in die Schule.
Ich gehe ins Einkaufszentrum.
Ich gehe ins Restaurant.
Ich gehe in die Bank.
Ich gehe an die Bushaltestelle.
Ich gehe zur Friseurin.
Ich gehe zum Arzt.
Ich gehe zu Tim.
Ich gehe nach Hause.
Ich gehe nach Berlin.
Was wirst du am Wochenende machen?
Was hast du mich gefragt?
Ich habe dich gefragt, was du
am Wochenende machen wirst?
Ich weiss es noch nicht.
Ich habe keine Pläne.
Ich fahre mit meiner Familie in die Berge.
Dort werden wir wandern.
Ich werde Ski fahren.
Ich werde ausschlafen.
Warum bist du nach Deutschland gekommen?
Ich bin nach Deutschland gekommen, weil
ich hier eine Arbeit gefunden habe.
ich von meiner Heimat flüchten musste.
Ich bin nach Deutschland gekommen,
weil meine Frau Deutsche ist.
Warum bist du glücklich?
Sorry. Ich habe nicht richtig
zugehört. Was hast du mich gefragt?
Ich wollte wissen, warum du glücklich bist.
Ich bin glücklich, weil die Sonne scheint.
Ich bin glücklich, weil ich die
Deutschprüfung bestanden habe.
Ich bin glücklich, weil meine
Fussballmannschaft gewonnen hat.
Ich bin glücklich, weil ich
einen neuen Job gefunden habe.
Ich bin glücklich, weil ich mich verliebt habe.
Warum bist du traurig?
Das möchte ich dir nicht erzählen.
Komm schon! Mir kannst du schon
erzählen, warum du traurig bist.
Ich bin traurig, weil es seit Tagen regnet.
Ich bin traurig, weil meine Katze gestorben ist.
Ich bin traurig, weil meine
Freundin mich verlassen hat.
Ich bin traurig, weil mir gekündigt worden ist.
Wann bist du nervös?
Ich bin nervös, wenn ich eine Prüfung habe.
Ich bin nervös, wenn ich
nicht gut geschlafen habe.
Ich bin nervös, wenn ich viel Arbeit habe.
Ich bin nervös, wenn ich
viel Kaffee getrunken habe.
Ich bin nervös, wenn ich Auto fahre.
Wann wirst du wütend?
Ich werde wütend, wenn ich im Stau stehe.
Ich werde wütend, wenn ich früh aufstehen muss.
Ich werde wütend, wenn jemand zu spät kommt.
Ich werde wütend, wenn meine
Kinder ihr Zimmer nicht aufräumen.
Ich werde wütend, wenn die Nachbarn Lärm machen.